Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is
going to be my new DC comic con trailer
video they just released details on the
online version of comic con that they're
doing this summer all the trailers and
the footage they're going to release is
called DC fandom so we'll break it all
down I'll be doing videos and Easter
eggs for everything when it happens
later this summer so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all those videos and I will do some
special comic con giveaways as part of
that stuff too but big details starting
with number five first big thing is the
actual comic con twenty20 event DC is
doing their own comic con Saturday
August 22nd like that teaser says this
is all separate by themselves from the
San Diego comic con virtual event so if
you guys didn't see comic con actually
had to cancel the in real life event for
July this summer just because of the
virus when they did that they said that
they were going to do a virtual online
version of comic con but nobody knew
what the panels would be like are they
going to release comic con trailers because
there's no big Hall H panel for any of
the studios
so what DC has done now it says that
they're doing their own separate event
by themselves it's not just going to be a
giant Zune call with Robert Pattinson
Matt Reeves in the cast of all the
upcoming DC movies they're using some
special tech to make it feel more like
an interactive experience on a special
website that they're going to create for it
so no they won't be streaming all the
panels on their YouTube channels or
anything like that everything will be
coming from one of their websites they
haven't posted a link for that yet so I
assume they're still building it out and
beta testing
I assume it's going to be like a
supercharged version of HBO Max or the
DC streaming service and then they'll
just host all that content and all the
panels on there forever unless they roll
it into the main DC website later it'll
be available to everyone around the
world so don't worry they'll be posting
about that on their social channels in
August so don't worry about missing any
of the information of course I'll be
doing videos about that stuff then too
anyway they didn't say if we'd have to
pay for access to all that content but
it'll either be super cheap like way
cheaper than buying a ticket to the
actual comic con in real life or it'll
be free and they'll just pay for it
through the cost of all the merch
they sell but there's also going to be a
separate San Diego virtual comic con
event online during the weeks of July
that the normal comic con would have
happened but they haven't announced what
panels are going to happen during that but
like I said because there is no big Hall
H event happening for any of the studios
everyone at all the different studios
Marvel DC are releasing their comic con
trailers differently this year I'll talk
about the Marvel stuff at the end of the
video after I talk about all the DC
trailers that they're going to release all
the DC trailers and footage that they're
going to release are happening at the DC
fandom Comic Con not the San Diego Comic
Con event hopefully that clears up some
of the confusion I'm sure people won't
see this video and they'll still be
asking questions about it in a month so
don't worry I'll remind people when I do
more videos about DC stuff but what are
they actually going to be doing at this
event so number four DC announced that
they're going to be doing panels for pretty
much every single movie and TV show and
video game that they have right now or
coming up for those of you wondering
about that new Batman game that they've
been teasing for a while there is going
to be a lot of video game stuff
happening at this online virtual event
there'll be a Comic Con panel for the
Justice League Snider cut the Batman
movie with Matt Reeves and Robert
Pattinson the Suicide Squad movie with
James Gunn Wonder Woman 1984 of course
because that movie is coming out in
October now right after the panels
happen there's even going to be a Comic Con
panel for the Black Adam movie with the
rock if you can believe it and they
haven't even started filming that yet so
three which comic con trailers and
footage are they actually going to show
off well the way the reports are
describing it they're dropping first
looks for the Justice League Snyder cut
the Batman movie The Suicide Squad movie
in a new Wonder Woman 1984 trailer an
early preview of The Black Adam movie
same for Shazam - and that doesn't
include any of the upcoming TV shows
which they'll also be dropping teasers
for - but because of the virus people
haven't been filming anything
so there's play not going to be a ton of TV
footage for them to show off they didn't
specify whether or not they'd be
releasing more concept teasers or
previews of the big-budget HBO Green
Lantern series Justice League dark or
the other DC HBO series that they're
doing
you're welcome Canada most of the focus
on the event though is going to be on the
upcoming movies in the TV shows Gimli
says they'd be doing a lot of video game
stuff there too which is why I say they
might have their new big Batman game
reveal with some footage but I know less
about what's going on with the new video
game stuff than I do about the movies
and the TV shows
I just know I'd be getting a lot of
questions about possible new Batman game
stuff happening this summer number two
the Batman Comic Con teaser is probably
just going to be smaller clips in previews
since they only had a chance to film a
little of the Batman before everyone
went on lockdown
probably a full Catwoman reveal and the
costume the villain reveals for the
penguin the Riddler a better preview of
the new Batmobile in a much much cleaner
look at Robert Pattinson 'he's new
Batman suit then they showed up in that
first teaser trailer earlier this year
so if you wonder why Matt Reeves has
been sitting on a lot of that Batman
stuff so far not revealing too much it's
because they've been waiting for this
big DC event later this year
he'll also probably reveal a little more
about what his version of Gotham is
going to look like with more concept art
and behind the scenes and explain what's
going on during the events of the movie
and more about his creative inspiration
for this new version of Batman without
being super spoilery about it we already
know it's going to be more of a
detective neo-noir type of story based
on Batman the long Halloween so
hopefully he'll just clarify some of
that the new Suicide Squad movie
finished filming a long time ago so they
have all the footage that they want to
show off solid chance for a full
Suicide Squad trailer but James Gunn
will probably explain more about how his
new movie is related to the previous
Suicide Squad movie because technically
it's not supposed to be a reboot and
when they said that my assumption was
they would just explain that something
terrible or hilarious happened to the
previous quote-unquote version of the
team and there would be everybody from
the first movie but something happens
and Amanda Waller just needs to put a
new version of the team together I did a
video for the first look teaser from
last year and there were a ton of super
weird deep cut characters from the
comics everyone was confused why their
costumes seemed so comic-book II in
over-the-top my early prediction at the
time was that that was just part of the
joke of the movie that the team is
supposed to be expendable and they'll
have a version of the team at the
beginning of the movie that just gets
killed off in some hilarious way before
they introduced the
actual team even though Margot Robbie's
Harley Quinn is in it again the movie is
not crossing over with the birds-of-prey
movie or anything like that it just said
during a different period in her life
when she's not with the birds of prey
but because it's still her and because
it's not a reboot the movie is still
connected to Justice League and the
other DC EU movies so we'll see what
kind of Easter eggs references and jokes
they make about the first movie in about
Justice League James Gunn also clarified
the Jared Leto's Joker is not going to
be involved with the movie at all so
don't expect to see him during it I
cannot wait to find out who Nathan
Fillion is playing this is Flula Borg if
you can believe it and Pete Davison is
also playing a character a lot of people
felt like Nathan Fillion might be
playing arms fall off boy but James Gunn
actually shot that rumour down so he's
playing some other weird obscure
character I'm assuming he's not in the
entire movie and he just part of a team
that gets killed off in some hilarious
way they're doing a new version of King
shark John Cena is even in the movie
playing peacemaker Dave Bautista was
actually going to be in the movie to
talk about James gun guardians of the
galaxy Easter eggs but there was a
scheduling conflict so John Cena is
playing the character peacemaker the
Dave Bautista would have played and even
more Marvel crossover Easter eggs Taika
Waititi is also playing a character
during the movie but it's a big mystery
so it might wind up being another big
motion capture character I'll post a
link at the end of this to the other
larger video that I did about all these
first looks and teasers from last year
but number one obviously everyone's also
asking what about Marvel's comic con
panel are they also going to do what DC
is doing and announced their own
separate online comic con trailer event
for all the movies in the Disney Plus
series because until Comic Con was
cancelled they had a ton of trailers and
footage to show off and that doesn't
include any of the mandalorian season 2
and the Star Wars stuff that they're
working on separately so if you guys
don't remember Marvel has actually
already done a version of what DC is
doing this year too in the past a couple
years ago Kevin Feige said that they
weren't ready to announce everything for
Marvel phase 3 at the July comic con
hall age panel so a little while later
in the year during a separate event he
invited a bunch of journalists to a
private Marvel phase 3 reveal event
until them all their Marvel phase 3
movie plans that they had not revealed
in Hall age about Benedict Cumberbatch
becoming their new Doctor
Trainz he showed off some special
footage and teasers this is actually a
clip from that event where he just like
sitting down having a chat with all
these journalists about hey these are
the big plans and things that we're
doing during Marvel phase 3 they'll
probably use it to release their full
Avengers Falcon and Winter Soldier
trailer a wandavision trailer and maybe
the first Marvel Eternals trailer
remember all this stuff isn't kicking
off til August 22nd for all the DC
trailers and footage so don't worry
about missing that they'll be making a
whole bunch more noise about that when
we get to August everyone click here for
that Suicide Squad to first look teaser
video and click here for my brand new
Man of Steel to Superman video to find
out what's going on with that movie
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!